recently at my job we got a new
supervisor one who happens to be retired
army after 20 years he and I had a
pretty heavy run-in - which resulted in
getting HR involved the end result was
that I would not be written up for what
he claimed I was doing he tried to make
an example out of me almost as soon as
he got here assuming I was easy - he
assumed I was an easy target anyways to
the point even though he and I had a
falling-out I'd still like to see the
guy succeed at his job and become a
great leader after listening to your
podcast over the last month I'm making
an effort to improve our relationship at
this job instead of just avoiding the
man I've reached I've recently purchased
your book extreme ownership how would
you suggest I present this book to my
new supervisor and read or to read
without him feeling as if I'm belittling
him as to say he needs work on his
leadership I think he could benefit from
it greatly good question yeah it's
actually a question I've answered on
here before but I'll answer it again
because I even learned when I repeat
sure this is my latest version of what I
tell people in the situation yeah
updated version sir cuz you get better
at things you figure out better ways to
overcome challenges especially when
you're presented with the same challenge
over and over again which I kind of am
yeah some challenges like this one so
here's what here's what you do you give
it to him and you say you know hey boss
or hey person hey I got this book and
I'm trying to really emulate the
principles that are in this book it
really hit me and I would I was
wondering if I could ask you a favor if
you could just look through this book
kind of see what the principles are and
then if you see me falling out of line
with the principles that are in this
book let me know so I can fix them basic
things like if I'm not taking ownership
of problems if I'm if I'm not keeping
things simple if I'm not supporting
other people around me covering and
moving for them just let me know that's
all I'm asking because I'm really trying
to do a better job could you do that for
me so then the person says well yeah
okay fine you know and then they read
the book and when they read the book
sure there's a chance that they'll be
thinking like oh this book is about
everyone else and it's not about me
right all right that's possible there is
also a chance a higher chance that they
read the book and go move I make a lot
of excuses and I blame other people all
the time I'm probably not doing a great
job as a leader and that might be
subconscious I see that sometimes now
where people are subconsciously making
adjustments because they don't want to
admit that they're the person that's
that that the problem they don't want to
admit that they're the problem so they
make these little adjustments kind of
subconsciously other people will tell me
that the boss is like changing oh yeah
they're they're changing their game they
won't admit it but they are changing
their game so that's what you hope for
is that they do they go through that
trance that transformation from you know
not taking ownership and treating people
bad and not trying to build
relationships and all that stuff that
makes them into a bad leader into taking
ownership building relationships
covering moving keeping things simple
all the stuff that makes you a good
leader that's what the hope is now
there's also a chance that this person's
gonna hold a grudge mmm right we we got
a deal with that and I'll Tarrant Lee
talking to someone that had stepped on
the toes of another business another
division inside their business another
sales division and you know salespeople
are sort of known for being a protective
and aggressively protective of their
territory well this guy kind of stepped
into their territory a little bit cause
cause some bad bad vibes giant rift
knees you don't know what should I do
you know I I feel like all this
animosity now and it's one of those
times where I just said to myself well
what would I actually do if I was in
that situation how would I try and get
this problem solved well what I would do
is walk up to the person who I stepped
into their territory and cause problems
and I'd say hey hey I want to tell you I
totally was out of line when I stepped
in your territory that that was
completely my fault and you know I was
just got target fixation which is bad I
didn't talk to you which is bad I
stepped into your world which is bad and
I left the disaster
and I I'm sorry that's that all that
stuff everything that I just said all my
fault and I want to let you know that I
completely recognized it and number one
anything I can do to try and redeem that
and make it up and make you realize that
and anything I can do to support and
help you move forward I don't I will not
let that happen again I just want to let
you know that so boom just step up be
humble apologize and say hey can you
what kind of you to help you what can I
do support you that's where I would go
with these with this question and then
it's sort of an addition to that
question yeah yeah it's kind of like you
know when you when you give your boss
the book right and be like hey this is
what I'm doing is that kind of like when
you when you get you know like it's on
my hands bad bad breath and then you put
in gum you know you eat some gum and you
say hey you want some gum yeah yeah it's
very similar you just break out the gum
you know I always like to do this you
know just to make sure I was like to
have a piece of gum just to make sure
you know yeah not funny or you want one
yeah yeah you could have yeah you might
want to take two